louise patino just 21 years old
out of colombia and he will take the
hill
and a cut in the miss he takes care of a
shed to pick up his first strikeout
and he gets him strikes him out the o2
and oh a dandy
gretchen could do nothing but take it
and it's a strike
on that outside corner left-hander
hyunjin ryu
making his fifth start already of the
season 2-2 swing and a miss got him with
a good fastball at 91
two down
down to third comes up on espinal and he
cannot recover
and brousseau is aboard
[Applause]
now listen that ball was absolutely
skull
no question about it rudder at second
two down
one two swing and a miss ryu strikes out
wendell
to finish off the raise
ground ball headed into center tier
meyer has himself a base hit
aggressively turns the bag right there
at first and hangs on
well i'll tell you i i love when kier
meyer does that
and especially when you're playing
outside of the division
there's a base hit center
argo makes the turn and holds on the
rays
took up the two out single by margot
looks like they're gonna take him out of
the game where you felt something and
he is coming out of the game
boy is that unfortunate not sure i
didn't see anything
unusual in a follow-through or anything
like that
but boy oh boy that's the last thing the
blue jays need
but he drews a pitch and then
danny jansen kind of walked to the mound
of the umpire as if danny said hey i got
to go check him out something's not
right
two and two on simeon
fleming likes to work quickly 2-2 on the
way to gravel to the right side and a
base head
with only the first baseman diaz over
there a lot of room
that'll be a base hit for simeon uriel
trying to bunt for a base hit
and he succeeds he is called safe at
first despite a good play
by brasso first and third with one out
and now it's santiago espinal
and again the one-two swing and a little
soft liner into center
for a base hit simeon into score on an
rbi single by espinal
and the blue jays take a one to nothing
lead
and uh cutting the miss he strikes him
out
a little bit of a foul ball a little
foul tip
on that and saw a line drive and a
bait's head
is aboard
so there's a leadoff single
[Applause]
that's gonna be a fair ball by the bag
up the left field line
and to make the pick up yurio jr
mejia can advance only to second but on
that base hit
the reigns will have two on with nobody
out this is a high leverage situation
right here for tyler chatwood 3-2
and he got him swinging a miss to get a
rosarina for a big second out
that that's two two and some change uh
oh
and that ball is
caught margot coming in on that sinking
fly ball and got there just in the nick
of time
mark wagner went out there from first
base to
make the call and he hesitated for a
moment to make sure
yeah this is easy today's all-state good
hands
goes to manuel margot that ball right
off the heel of the glove
into the webbing and saving what could
have been a disaster for the raise if
that ball
hits the turf and gets by him
and that will take care of junior
his 31st birthday right like this is no
kid this is a guy who's been
he's been working for this for a long
time has never
pitched in the major leagues but it
looks like he's going to get his
opportunity today
as a 31 espionage lines one in the left
and that is his second hit of the ball
game
big aggressive turn at first and they'll
get it back in to force him back to the
bat
again the o2 and a fastball gets him
strike three called
d has the lead and the one-two swing and
a miss got him with a breaking ball down
and away
a very big out for david phelps end of
seven at the top and the blue jays still
lead one to nothing
and right there loud
position perfectly and that's the first
down
some lewis head retires the first man he
faces
dealing with machete now vladimir
guerrero jr
a little ground ball right side head's
gonna have to cover it he takes that
floater
and a nice job by diaz that's not
easy to do and the combination of diaz
and head
recording out number two yeah and the
thing is duane
it got to him quick enough that he had
time to kind of set his feet here
but he was like ah you know what i'm
feeling it right now i'm going to throw
a little floater over the defense as i
backpedal
and lewis head he knows where to go
let him right to the bag
[Applause]
the pitch is skied to right
or goes there and he makes the catch so
the young man out of houston texas who
now lives in katy texas
lewis had a one two three inning in his
major league debut
3-2 now to simeon swung on and missed
strike three pulled the string and
simeon with an
awkward looking cut is retired for one
out
one line to right field that'll get down
for a base hit
a two for four day for goriel
both teams have had problems defending
the stolen base
and it gets one off the end of the bat
and that's going to drop for a base hit
boy a couple of soft liners won by
goriel one by panic
and the blue jays have a couple of men
[Applause]
on
on the infield left side brosso the
third baseman coming in towards the
mound will make the catch
and the blue jays will leave a couple of
that on to the bottom of the nine the
rafael dolis
looking for three more outs
[Applause]
first pitch on the way fastball and a
ground ball to second
panic has it on to first and the blue
jays will
win it six pitchers combine
on a five hit shutout in a one to
nothing win
as the blue jays go into the trop and
take
two out of three